in this morning's ion money how to avoid
overspending this holiday season but
it's okay if you overspend on my present
more than 56% of consumers have already
started their holiday shopping I don't
know any of those people and about 48
million Americans are still paying off
debt from the last holidays I know some
of those we aspire to people about their
holiday shopping plans we love to shop
on Black Friday
[Music]
I do online because stores are so
chaotic people running around camping
out just not my style I do not shop on
Black Friday at all it's so crazy it's
hectic got my credit card so of this day
I would think I would like to actually
try to spend less and try to make more
gifts and do more like handcrafted type
of things and my husband's an accountant
also and so we're very good about
sticking to the budget
I don't never have budget because you
should treat yourself I actually don't
really like spending my money that much
we try to set a budget every year and my
wife goes over every year is here good
morning Jill don't give me any of those
handcrafted items okay please we need to
have a budget right yeah I mean I think
it's really hard to actually hate your
goals if you don't know what they are go
back to last year figure out what you
spent it's really good to pull up that
credit card statement maybe from
December January your bank account
statement check it out it's a little
daunting I know but then you want to
like Santa create your list for this
year and assign those dollar amounts and
then really try to stay within it
remember you know one of the things they
talked about the crafty presence and it
sounds kind of goofy but you know what's
interesting is that research tells us
that experiential presence tend to make
the longest lasting impact so if I say
to you Anthony I could have gotten you a
gorgeous tie or let's go take a walk in
Central Park you'll remember the park
walk more than you will the time it
bring if they trot you can try that if
you'd like to try let's say how can
technology help people you know we've
got all these great apps to really keep
us on track there's one called gift stir
which is essentially almost like a gift
registry for you for your friends but it
can really keep you at least paying
attention to that those numbers and then
we have apps that help you compare
prices so we have shop Euler and that's
one where you get some circulars out
there a shops savvy question which I'm
going to make sure I got the right name
shop savvy which does price comparisons
with those codes with those QR codes we
also have honey which is an extension to
a browser which can actually help you
search for items across the board again
some research can really help save some
money what about those layaway plans
payment installations do you really save
money what's up grandma
yeah okay so here's what's interesting
about these these have become more and
more popular so you get to the checkout
and this is where you get the choice now
they can be cheaper than going on a
credit card
it really can in their fixed payments
here's the problem a lot of people will
say if I make a late payment there's
still a huge charge and there can also
be some charges to actually create the
plan the thing that's hard about it for
me is that it can create an impulse and
I don't think that that's what we really
want to do this holiday season again you
want to be very specific this is what
I'm going in for the other thing that
happens at the register is if they will
say well you could save 20% right now if
you sign up for the store credit cards
so I want people to avoid this and
retailers are gonna hate me for saying
this but hey they don't like me anyway
so it's okay is it is that you'll you
will get that reduction but the problem
is every time you apply for new credit
it's a ding on your credit score and you
open up new credit it can adversely
affect you so let's say you get that 20%
discount and it's a $50 item and you end
up paying more interest because your
credit score goes down over the course
of the next few years clearly not a good
deal all right Jill I know I'm the
buzzkill gosh Grinch has been here oh
yeah all right thanks